yeah
[Music]
thank you it's fantastic to be back in
Paris so 22 years ago in in May I did 10
days of hard work I didn't sleep much
but before that in February I was
recruited my friends said you know come
out to the coast well have a few laughs
do scheme in the browser and by the time
I got there of course it was supposed to
look like Java and this Christophe said
be a little language I knew after I got
into Netscape 2 that he it would either
die quickly and Microsoft would
completely replace it or it would be
around for 20 years or longer and I said
this to my cubicle made at Netscape Jeff
Weinstein so he can testify to that
but people get impatient and they get
tempted by things like you know Windows
on the PC and you think the web will die
every 10 years I mean it doesn't it just
keeps going and that's why I like this
quote from Ian Hickson things that are
impossible just take longer I'm going to
cover why that is necessarily so with
the web and the best way to cope with
that fact I've been around a long time
so there was Netscape JavaScript I found
in Mozilla with jamie zawinski and other
people did Firefox which he started the
browser market nobody thought that was
possible taught Google how to do Chrome
and for me the interesting innovation is
now going into peer-to-peer networks
that are not just for downloading songs
but but now for things like crypto
currencies and involved in those as well
as in the ad blocking trafficking
protection and privacy by design
I think privacy tech is going to be big
in the next 10 years I'm glad that
Europe is doing its part there how do we
cope with the fact that in any regime of
web browsers you're going to have
competition you might have a near-death
experience where internet explorer takes
ninety five percent of the market but
Firefox show how to restart it and I
think that will be a lesson that it's
not forgotten that means you'll have
competing browsers working in standards
bodies and they have to find a modus
vivendi they have to get along and
best way that I've learned to do it it's
just not smoke but to socialize and this
has been going on with JavaScript since
1996 November 1 at scape took JavaScript
to the ECMO
standards body at that time it was the
European computer Manufacturers
Association here is the Secretary
General of the time have bon vivant I
remember fondly he's retired now
he lived in Geneva he is a Dutch surname
but he's belgian-born a polymath
raconteur a really fun guy and that I
think taught me something that we've
tried to keep going in this committee
that you have dinners together and you
try not to hold grudges or let
personality conflicts which are
inevitable get the better of you and and
Netscape while it lasted did that and
Microsoft even played relatively fair as
they took the browser market but then
they shut it all down
so with Firefox we brought it back and
we actually restarted it I went to
Geneva in 2005 after Firefox 100 came
out in November of 2004 and I said the
on let's let's bring the band back
together it's time to improve JavaScript
again and you know Microsoft was kind of
like no do we really have to we're doing
c-sharp but Macromedia had used a
version of JavaScript called
ActionScript in the flash player and so
we formed an alliance with them and this
led to a bunch of learning and
socializing and philosophizing that I
think is important I used this famous
painting by Raphael there's a detail
from it that's Doug Crockford on the
left and then me on the right dubs
always pointing up and I'm like keep it
real there are bad problems in committee
so it's inevitable because you get
conflicts of personality and conflicts
of style and and sort of deep deeply
held beliefs that aren't fully unpacked
into chains of reasoning it's hard to
reason together if people come from
really different schools of thought so
we've learned how to cope with this by
not rushing to any conclusion when
you're doing language design you're
solving many problems which cross cut or
trade off against each other
you have to take the the hermeneutic
spiral as it's called you have to be
willing to go around several times
before you close on a design and
sometimes you have to throw things out
and start over again that's happened for
instance with es6 proxies you have to
avoid the temptation to say well I have
developers that are solving this complex
compound problems so I'm just going to
give them a complex compound solution
that's kind of a fixed composite
function because that usually doesn't
work it's usually the case that when you
decompose it you find that you've got
composable parts and what we'd rather do
is what the scheme scheme in the browser
the scheme report says in its very first
paragraph it says break the language
down in two orthogonal primitives that
work well together so that's been the
job of the committee and coming to an
understanding of those primitives and
minimizing that the choice of primitives
choice of axioms has been important
then there's the ugly I shouldn't linger
on it to code you find people sometimes
but they're competitive interests get
the better of them and so they use
essentially bad faith arguing they find
sort of vague excuses for not doing
something and they all have some truth
and they're all half-truths you ain't
gonna need it don't scare the junior
people you know don't make it into Java
but you have to actually get into the
concrete aspects to get past those
objections because that could be true of
many things that we want and while we
don't want to make JavaScript into Java
languages grow there's a great talk by
guy Steele where he starts with a subset
of the English language and presenting
the talk and then he grows his subset as
he gives the talk languages grow that's
how they how they progress so we've had
to cope with the good the bad and the
ugly and we've made progress the old
days were when Netscape had some market
power which was going away and we got
ps1 done based on my work in Netscape 2
& 3 atmosphere to just historical
curiosity was the ISO version of es1
es 3 was the big one it had a bunch of
new things it had fully nested functions
and closures function expressions a lot
of you may have heard about es 4 I spent
many years on that that's what
with Macromedia which we got bought by
adobe tried to really get microsoft to
sit up and pay attention by doing the
big language that had been envisioned
even in 1999 by somebody in Baltimore
[ __ ] watt of Netscape who I gave the
keys to the kingdom to me he designed
this language ActionScript 3 has a lot
of aspects of it it actually got
implemented by Microsoft on the server
side in 2000 but they never promoted it
and didn't not standardize it yes four
failed but the failure was important
because the committee then with my
codename harmony found a way to come
together and work on ES 5 which was the
no new syntax 3.1 kind of incremental
step from ES 3 that had been started
concurrently with es 4 Doug Crockford
and others descending from es 4 in
public we pulled everybody together and
we've been operating in a much better
mode since then es 6 obviously is a big
leap forward a lot of backlog had to be
absorbed but now we've got on to a
better cadence there's a backstory some
of this is you've heard about schema in
the browser that was a lie well it was a
vain hope let's say there were other
things that I did in hurry in the 90s
that I do regret no do-while switch
try-catch that's all ok I think that
worked out regular expressions thoughts
atom UI based on 404 sorry I met Larry
wall in 97 I said hey I'm putting pro
regular expressions in JavaScript that
he turned green he looked very unhappy
he was changing them for pro 5 and pro 6
is even even yeah different because he
had could do a clean slate language the
restarting of tc39 I mentioned that that
was painful because Microsoft didn't
want to do much the language until they
did and when they did it was still this
sort of half-hearted thing until I think
chrome came out and that really woke
them up so we had you know amazing
performance work in JavaScript engines
we even had Google to say that
JavaScript cannot be repaired so we'll
do - now dart and I told him it wouldn't
work they didn't listen
that actually leaked
an accidental global message post by
somebody on the tc39 committee whose
name is on it he's not the author of
that - memo but he he turned white and
went over to another Googler during the
November 2010 meeting and tapped him on
the shoulder in theatrical fashion and
they all all the Googlers decamp to the
hall and we said what's going on as the
singularity arrived has has Sergey or
Larry canceled free you know cookies
only later did we learn that my friend
on the committee from Google
accidentally posted this this internal
memo which the JavaScript must be
replaced it was like Joe we love
JavaScript but it must be replaced and
it's just really hard to replace there's
something like successful DNA about
JavaScript once it's in there you're
gonna heart then getting rid of it
another thing I'm particularly proud of
in the last 10 years was this sort of
discovery carving nature at the joint
this play-doh set of science of azzam
j/s inside of JavaScript if you look at
C code and some of you probably know C
code you have you have a statically
typed language with machine types and
there is fast C code notably games games
were always torturing the hardware can
you map that to JavaScript it turns out
you can and this was discovered at first
I think by alone Sakai maybe by others
concurrently or a little bit before at
Adobe labs and the trick is to use the
bitwise operators that I put in most of
them come from C one of them comes from
Java so I'm really glad I put those
those like vertical bar or operator in
because that if it hadn't been in there
from 1995 what we've been hard to add
later and the fact that it was there all
along meant we could do incredibly fast
JavaScript also needed typed arrays from
WebGL and this is this is not meant for
reading but just the dynamic nature of
JavaScript has led to a common
architecture and all I think all the top
engines now the open source engines
where you have interpreting and you have
sort of a fast just-in-time compiler of
baseline compiler and then you have a
much more aggressive compiler that
operates when there's really hot code
running and the fast subset of
JavaScript that is Assam Jas the
statically typed fast subset allows
bypassing the baseline JIT and the
interpreter which has paved the way for
when it's webassembly which we're all
excited about
a little more backstory I I realized
after Alan where's Brock did a great job
as editor of a 2006 to and as we we got
es5 done that he was not having at
Microsoft so I recruited him to Mozilla
and we did es6 that was a coup and I was
glad to have Alan on the crew it was all
there the formalization of Azzam J's as
a type system was by Dave Herman the
exploratory compiler driven work was by
alone Sakai and Luke Wagner did the
amazing compiler that bypasses those
jets and does a full sort of whole
module compilation to machine code and
it all came together in one week in the
fall of 2012 in Raleigh North Carolina
and Epic Games Unreal Engine 3 was
ported in four days you know you had to
get the audio working using OpenGL
mapped to web audio you had to get
OpenGL mapped to WebGL fix a few
compiler bots and suddenly this game is
running at 60 frames a second Tim
Sweeney the founder of Epic said he
thought it would take years to get there
I think this pretty much killed the
portable Native Client and other such
approaches it was at that point
inevitable that webassembly would emerge
Babel J's was interesting because 10 or
20 years ago people would say I'm never
writing code with a compiler I'm writing
JavaScript to the metal and and now
they've gotten used to using tools and I
think that's beneficial linting but even
type systems typescript and so on
and at some point I think the committee
will standardize some kind of type
system we have a new proposal from some
folks at Google it's going to take a
while it there's disagreement between
flow and typescript and there's a lot of
evolution exploration to do you know how
modern software works on a rapid release
cycle like six weeks cycle for you know
firefox chrome brave some of their
browsers are more like an annual cycle
the admin committee is now going on an
annual cadence which is good because it
gets rid of that schedule chicken
problem where if people feel like
they're going to miss they can just go
to the next year they don't try to hold
up everything to jam and something
doesn't fit and as predicted Google
threw in the towel on dart and if I'm at
the same time I think threw in the towel
on Korriban Native Client it's not gonna
go across
you know what assembly was out in 2015
June so there's been a lot of
interesting backstory that you may not
hear everywhere I sometimes try to share
this this is at a Brooklyn Jas Meetup
when I said you know something's changed
some say the same Apple of still Apple
other companies sort of trade roles and
and attitudes and and right after that
of course Microsoft open-source their
chocolate core JavaScript engine we're
still waiting for edge but it could
happen it was a good move I'll just
share what in detail one of the new
things that's coming into es 2018 or
something I don't know what it'll be
it's getting implemented in all the
engines now all the open source engines
and that's big and you know how when you
start counting up in JavaScript you get
past 53 minute nature you lose precision
I didn't have time to do any other
number types and I did put in those
bitwise operators so implicit in
JavaScript are 32-bit signed and
unsigned integers other than that you're
out of luck and if you want to go to
really big numbers like the finance
people do you end up using your own big
decimal or big integer library but we're
putting big in into the language and it
will have nice and suffix for literal
syntax they'll have operators that work
sensibly even with some safe conversions
for comparisons it will have the ability
to name property keys and caste to
narrow or integer types which is
important for Asmodeus because big int
will matter there this is how we're
going to project 64-bit types through
JavaScript begins back into system or
great machine types in Azzam Jas I I had
to get this ball rolling by saying let's
do 64-bit types and a couple of people
Dan Arenberg notably said let's let's
let's do big in sand we can make it just
as fast it'll be better and dart had big
in so we know it's better so that's good
I'll put these slides you see the links
here's an example Fibonacci function in
JavaScript nicely using D structuring
and computing Fibonacci numbers and if
you go up to fib 79 you run out of 53
bits of anticipate one blames me for I
Triple E floating point problems like
not a number
somebody put a tweet up with a
oscilloscope with not a number this is
like a Tektronix or HPS Losco and he
said it's JavaScript and I said no it's
not it's C code it's it's um it's AI
trevally but I'll take the blame with
big int we get rid of this we got the
true answer in green instead of the
wrong one you ready just to show you
that the committee is it's not messing
around these are a selection of the
stage three proposals those unit of node
realize import as a function it's hard
to do statically but it's coming
thanks to Dominic Google Dom identical
oh so dynamic import pretty big michael
fiqar is championing flat map and
flattening for all the functional fans
out there Seb mark page at Facebook is
doing rest and spread for objects that's
what the third line shows we're evolving
classes and actually I think other
things to have private fields and
methods and the design is more like Ruby
I think there's still some details being
debated there but this is at stage three
a synchronous iteration so you can do
for a weight of and you can totally it
face the pain of promises a bunch of
regular expression fixes look behind
pack in 1997 just missed es 3 it was
just being added to Perl when we were
cutting off the es 3 regular expression
features so finally getting a look
behind assertions and unicode is getting
help and named property groups the /s
flag on regular expressions and there's
there's much more small proposals some
bigger ones I didn't cover here they all
have to go through a rigorous process to
get into the next version language but
it and the annual cycle we're going at
javascript will continue to evolve and
that's why I say almost bet on Jas and I
have to treat webassembly fairly because
it's another input language for the same
JavaScript VM that we all enjoy in
multiple browsers and oh yeah web pack
is pretty cool too thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]